hello everyone and welcome to another
video on the python series of tutorials
by simply learn
today we are going to learn about
classes and objects in python
so we are going to understand the basics
of object oriented programming in python
before i get started make sure to
subscribe to the simply launch channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update
so what is the class in python a class
is a virtual entity or a blueprint for
creating objects
a class in python provides a means of
bundling data and functionality together
you can think of a class
as a school so here school becomes your
class
a school has attributes about the
students classrooms labs playgrounds etc
hence the school can be called a class
and classrooms labs desks playground
assembly are the attributes or objects
of a class
a class comes into existence when it is
instantiated or initiated
we can create as many objects as
possible in a class now in python a
class is created using the keyword
called class
followed by the class name
the first string inside the class is
called docstring and has a brief
description of the class
below you can see the syntax of creating
a class in python we have the class
keyword followed by the class name this
should be a valid python name and then
you have a colon
below that you have the statements that
should be present inside the class
now let's look at an example of a class
in python
so here you can see we have created a
class called student
and we have two variables the student id
and the name of the student
and after that we have created a
function using the def keyword so this
is a user defined function and the name
of the function is called display
and inside
the display function we are
giving a parameter called self so here
the self parameter refers to the
current class object and accesses the
class variables we can use anything
instead of self
but
it must be the first parameter of any
function which belongs to the class
now moving ahead
so let's look at what is an object in
python
so an object is also called an instance
of a class and the process of creating
this object is called instantiation
now you need to create an object of the
class if you want to use the class
attributes in another class or method
now the procedure to create an object is
similar to a function call so
below you can see we have created a
object called stu and we have called the
class student using parenthesis so this
is how you create a class and after that
we are displaying
the message to be printed by calling the
class name followed by the function
which is present inside the class
so this example will create a new object
instance named stu
we can access the attributes of the
objects using the object name prefix
now moving ahead
let's understand the initialization or
init method in a python class
the init method is similar to
constructors in c plus and java
all classes in python have an init
function it is always executed when the
class has been initiated you can use the
init function to assign values to object
properties or other operations that are
necessary to do when the object has been
created
so the init function is called
automatically every time the class is
being used to create a new object
so here you can see we have used
the init method we have
defined using the def keyword then we
have parameter self name and age
so we are calling
the
class using this object called s1 and
then we have passed in the values for
neiman age that is delay and his age is
27 years and after that we are printing
the age and the name as well
all right now let's get started with our
demo on
classes and objects in python on the
jupyter notebook
so i am on my jupyter notebook let me
first go ahead and
rename my notebook to classes and
objects in python
all right i'll click on rename
first of all
let me show you how to create a simple
class
so i'm creating a new class
using the class keyword so this is
the keyword class and
followed by the keyword i have my class
name called new class
one thing to note here is the
class name should always be a valid
python name
i'll give a colon and in the next line
i'll just say
x equal to 50
so this x is a variable which is present
inside my
class called new class now if i run it
i have my new class created now if you
want to display the
value of x you can just say new class
dot x
now if i run this you can see here i
have my value printed which is 50.
now
we'll see another simple example to
create a class and to call that class
using
an object
so i'll say class
then i'll say
new class let's say 1
give a colon
and i'll create a variable called x
equal to 100 so my x is a variable which
is present inside new class 1 and holds
a value 100
now i'll give a comment
create object
so to create object i'll
define a variable called r let's say r
stands for result and then
i'll say
new class 1 so i'm calling my class
and then i'll say print
r which is my new object dot
x
let's run it you see here i have my
value printed of x which is 100 so this
is how you can
create or initiate a class using an
object
now let's see how you can use the self
parameter in a class
so i'll go ahead and create a class
called
student
give a colon
then i'll have some variables
or the
attributes of a student let's say the
student id is 10 and the name is
anderson
now
inside the class i'm going to
create a user-defined function called
display
so i've used my df keyword followed by
the
function name that is display and inside
the display function i'll use self as my
parameter
and then i'm going to say
print
self dot id i'll give a comma
and i'm going to print
my name so i have written self dot name
so i'll run this
and then
we're going to create an object called s
and we'll call our class
that is student and i'll say s dot
display
now let's run it and see the result you
can see it here
we have called the
class using this object called s so it's
displaying
the id that is 10 and the name that is
anderson
cool
now we are going to see an example where
we'll pass a dog string so in the slide
we discussed that the first
string inside the class is called a dot
string and has a brief description of
the class
so let me show you an example how to
pass in a doc string
i'll create a class again let's say
called student
give a colon
and then we'll have our message
which is essentially a doc string i'll
say this is a
student class
then i'll create a variable called age
let's say the student's age is 14
and then
i'll create a user defined function
called welcome
and
have myself
parameter
after that i'll say print
my message let's say hi
comma
welcome to
section
let's say b
and then
i'll come out of the class and we are
going to
print
class name that is student i'll say
student dot age
and then i'll say print i'll just scroll
down
student dot
then i'm going to use the
function name that is welcome
and after that
to print the
docstring message i'm going to say
my class name that is student
dot i'm going to use underscore
underscore doc underscore underscore
now we have created a class called
student that has a variable called age
so we are going to display the age of
the student and then
we are going to display the
doc string so here we are not going to
print the message which is present
inside the function called welcome
let's run it
you can see it here
we
have the message printed so first we are
printing the age of the student and then
we have the docstring message that is
this is a student class
all right
now let's move ahead we are going to see
how to use the
init function
in a class
so i'll say my comment init function
all right
i'll scroll down
and create another
class called student
this time we are going to use the init
function so i am writing def
space
underscore underscore init
underscore underscore
then we'll have our self parameter let's
say the next parameter is
name
and then we have the date of birth of
the
student
i'll say self
dot
name equal to
name
then i'll say
self dot
dob or d to birth equal to
a parameter that is
dob
and then
i'll say
my object let's say s1
i'm going to call my class student
and it will have
values of name and date of birth let's
say the name of the student is harry
and
the date of birth let's say it is
29
october
1992
all right
finally we are going to print
s1 dot name
and then i'll say print
s1 dot
data both
let's run it
you can see it here we have the name and
the date of birth of the student printed
cool
now you can also modify the objects that
you have created suppose i want to
change the
name from harry to virat because my
object was s1 dot name
harry i want to change this to virat let
me show you how to do it
this is very simple i'll just give a
comment that is modify objects
the way to do is you just
see the object name that is s1 followed
by the parameter that is name
equal to
let's say virat
now if i print
s1 dot name
i'll have virat instead of
harry
okay
now
if you want to delete the object
properties let's say i want to delete
one of the properties let us say i want
to delete name property of the student
to do that
i can use the del keyword followed by
the object name that is s1 and say s1
dot name
now if i print
s1 dot name it will throw an error
saying student object has no attribute
name because we are first deleting it
and then we are trying to print it and
hence
python cannot recognize this attribute
name
now you can also
delete objects that is all the objects
using the dl keyword
so this means we can delete both the
objects that we created above which is
name and date of birth
so the way to do is i'll just say dls1
so it will delete all the objects
that is s1 in this case
i'll run this
and then let's say i want to print
s1 dot
date of birth
you see it here
python says name s1 is not defined
because we deleted it
cool
now coming to the final section of the
demo we are going to create a simple
class with init method again
so this time my class name is let's say
animal
give a colon and then i'll write my
init method using the
df keyword
i'll say self comma
name that is the name of the animal as
the parameter
i'll say self dot name equal to name
and then
i'm going to create another function
called tef
which is essentially a welcome or a
greet message
and that has a parameter that itself
i'm going to print the greet message or
the greeting
i'll say hi
my name is
give a comma and then say self dot name
now i'm going to create
my object a1 to
[Music]
initiate my class
so i'll say animal which is the class
name let's say the name of the animal is
puppy
then i'm going to say even dot
greet
i'll use parenthesis let's run it
there you go
you see here we have a message printed
hi my name is
then
using the self dot name
argument or the parameter we are passing
in the value that is poppy all right so
that was our demo session on
python classes and objects so we saw how
to create a simple class in python and
then we saw how to create
objects to
call a class
and then
we
saw how to use the self parameter
after that we saw
how to
print a message that is present in the
docs string of a class
and then we
checked a few examples on using the init
method in a class then we learned how to
modify
objects and delete objects in a class
and finally we saw another example
on init method
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on python classes and
objects i hope it was useful and
informative if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comments section of the video thank you
for watching
[Music]
there if you like this video subscribe
to the simply learn youtube channel and
click here to watch similar videos turn
it up and get certified click here